- Happy Thanksgiving! It's
tomorrow, so happy Thanksgiving.
- Thanks. You too.
- But last time you were
here we didn't get to talk
about your daughter.
So how are you handling having a teenager?
I just want to know.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Because mine's seven right now.
- [Kelly] I feel like she's a teenager.
- [Machine Gun Kelly] 12 years old.-
[Audience] Aww.
- [Kelly] She is so stinking adorable.
(audience laughs)
And how you look is so awesome.
This is my favorite picture.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] This should
be your Christmas card.
- [Machine Gun Kelly] It's
my lock screen actually.
- [Audience] Aww.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love that.
Mine are my kids too.
- It's great!
I trust her opinion more
than I trust my own now.
She has her finger on
the pulse of what's hot.
Or if I'm doing a song
and it's the right one,
she'll confirm it.
- Oh I love that.
- She also has,
- Does she also tell you when it's crap?
(laughs)
- Oh yeah, for sure.
- Because my daughter
does and she's seven.
- But she always just
gets into funny phases.
Maybe she gets that from me,
except I run all mine into the ground.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- You wear it out?
- [Machine Gun Kelly] Yeah. I wear it out.
- Yeah.
- [Machine Gun Kelly] I
have this thing right now
where I'm like "respectfully."
I say anything
and then I just follow
it with, "respectfully."
- [Kelly] I say honestly.
- Yeah. Everyone's like, dude...
- [Kelly] And what does
that mean? Am I gonna lie?
I say honestly a lot
- But she has one, what
does she say right now?
Oh, she goes, "You thought you ate that?"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
And she has a bunch of uncles
because all of my band mates,
all of my friends or whatever,
are all like her uncles.
So if they ever are picking
on her or anything like that,
she's like, "You thought you ate that."
(audience laughs)
- What does it mean?
- I think it means, "Oh,
you thought that was funny?"
or you thought...
- [Kelly] Oh, you thought that was great?
- Or you thought you killed that?
- I'm going to steal that one
and I'm going to look so cool saying it.
(audience laughs)
And not like a mom at all. (laughs)
Is she into sports? Does she play sports?
- Yeah. Yeah. I just took
her to volleyball tryouts.
- [Kelly] Oh that's fun!
- She came up to me
with recruitment papers
and stuff like that. I was like,
"Whoa, what is this? The NBA draft?"
(audience laughs)
But my favorite part was,
I looked at the contract
and I was like, Casie, dude,
they're going to pay you $1,800.
- [Kelly] What?
- And I looked at it,
and then I looked closer,
and I was like, "Oh,
I have to pay $1,800."
(audience laughs and claps)
Right.
- I was like, what kind of school is this?
- That's what I said because she was like,
"I need you to take me to tryouts."
And this was in between,
on an off day of the tour.
So I went back to Cleveland
to take her to the tryouts,
and they came up, there was like 250 kids.
And they were like,
"Here, we want her on the national team."
- What?
- And it was super serious.
And I looked and I saw the $1,800.
I was like,
"Dude, you're like a
professional sports player."
(everyone laughs)
And it was me that had to...
- You're having to pay it.
- Yeah.
- I love volleyball.
It's such a fun thing.
Did you play sports?
- I played, no one will believe me
but I played football for a little bit.
- Why would I not believe you?
Aren't you from Texas?
Don't all men in Texas
when you're young play football?
(audience laughs)
- Well, I lived there for two weeks,
so technically I can't really say...
- Okay. Okay.
Even two weeks, when you're
there and they see a guy,
they're like, "Put a
football in your hand."
- Right.
- It's very Friday night lights.
- But then I went to Egypt,
and that's where I spent my
first six years of my life.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- I don't think they play
football much over there.
Except for the kick kind.
- That's the coolest thing ever though.
I've been to Egypt. It's a cool place.
- Yeah.
- Okay. Well wait, are
you the dad at the game?
When you go to the sporting
events, are you a yeller?
Are you that embarrassing dad?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I love it.
- I always roll deep to the games.
- [Kelly] You bring a posse?
- Yeah.
I more just kind of laugh
at what they're saying,
but last game we went
to, my dude was like,
so she served it, or she served it,
and it went to this person
who was the weakest link
in the section or whatever.
- Yeah.
- And my guy goes, "I'm
not telling you what to do,
but if you see something
you like keep going for it".
(Kelly and audience laugh)
Basically keep hitting it right there
and she's never gonna...
- Just keep killing that kid's confidence.
- Yeah. She's never going to return it.
- Oh my God.
- And I'm always just bummed like
what if their parent's a fan
and they just think that we're...
- [Kelly] Hassling their kids?
- Yeah. Trolling their kids.
- Hey, that kid sucks.
Serve it to that one!
- [Machine Gun Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- The mom on the end is like,
are you for real right now?
- Yeah, yeah.